[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans
audition publique sur lcp la chaîne
parlementaire lcp que l'histoire disait
françois mitterrand en ayant gagné la
présidentielle en 1981 eh bien quelle
histoire quelle tremblement terre
peut-on dire aussi après ces élections
législatives de juin 2022 un séisme
électoral qui sanctionne emmanuel macron
à quoi ressemble donc l'hémicycle du
palais bourbon ce soir quelques heures
après le vote des français et bien une
force centrale macro nist 246 députés
mais qui est très loin de la majorité
absolue
le bloc nu avec un peu moins de 150
députés un bataillon conséquent très
conséquent si la surprise évidemment de
ces législatives des députés est reine
sans pardon passons 89 89 et puis lee a
l'air désormais troisième groupe
d'opposition ils ont ils ont baissé de
plusieurs marches nous sommes à
l'assemblée nationale donc bien placé
pour dire que cet inédit cette situation
ça ressemble plus à la ivème république
cas au rapport de force législatif après
une présidentielle la france est-elle
gouvernable si emmanuel macron à une
solution on ne la connaît pas encore il
ne s'est pas exprimé l'opposition elle
tente de s'organiser pour s'opposer ou
pour bloquer bonsoir adrien 4 nages si
souvent merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
coordinateur de la france insoumise
félicitations vous êtes réélu député
dans votre circonscription du nord elle
est fille votre parti à propos si je
puis dire compte combien de députés
d'après vous parce que lcp a fait le
compte elle est bien placé aussi notre
chaîne pour faire les comptes et on a
dénombré 76 c'est autour de 80 il faut
encore stabilisée vous savez ceux qui
sont classés divers gauche où les
ultramarins tout ça va se stabiliser
dans les prochaines heures les prochains
jours mais c'est autour de 80 en effet
d'accord on verra et de toute façon on
fera les comptes quand les groupes
seront constitués et justement c'est
l'événement du jour adrian cnas jean luc
mélenchon a demandé tout à l'heure en
début d'après midi
devant les micros devant sans que j'aie
il a demandé à ce que la nuque restent
unis et constitue un seul groupe à
l'assemblée ça veut dire quoi c'est une
proposition que jean luc mélenchon en
formula le partenaire de la nouvelle
union populaire écologique et sociale
d'abord je vais insister sur le fait que
ce que nous avons fait avec la nouvelle
union populaire écologique et sociale on
va dire la nuque pour aller plus vite ça
n'est pas simplement un accord électoral
avant notre discuter répartition de
circonscription tout le reste à l'issue
d'élections présidentielles et du score
de jean luc mélenchon on a choisi de se
regrouper autour d'un programme partagé
et nous avons construit en l'espace de
trois semaines un programme ambitieux de
650 mesure 8 chapitres chiffre est
détaillé avec un objectif que nous nous
étions fixés celui de gouverner le pays
est de bâtir une autre majorité il était
prévu que chacun ensuite se constituer
en groupe à l'assemblée vous avez raison
marie est presque noir semblant vous
avez raison et je vais vous dire la même
chose jusqu'à hier soir c'était toujours
notre intention c'est à dire avoir des
groupes parlementaires constitué comme
groupe ayant leur autonomie à
l'assemblée nationale les différentes
composantes la france est soumise le
parti socialiste le parti communiste
français europe ecologie les verts et
avoir un fonctionnement en intergroupe
qui nous permettent de traiter de
manière hebdomadaire tous les sujets
communs de l'action d'un gouvernement
c'est nous gouvernement ou de
l'opposition qu'est ce qu'elle fait ce
qui a changé c'est ce que personne
n'avait prévu c'est le nombre de siège
du rassemblement national est donc une
situation politique qui est inédite et
qui nécessite que nous fassions la
démonstration du fait que nous sommes en
effet la première opposition en moment
puisque nous avons quelques 150
parlementaires de la nouvelle union
populaire et qu'il n'est pas question de
laisser la main au rassemblement
national qui réussit cette élection de
quelques dizaines de députés donc c'est
vous êtes assez transparent merci vous
dites voilà elle est fille devait être
la première force le premier groupe
d'opposition à l'assemblée de façon
incontestée on est 80 ils sont 89 et
pourront revendiquer d'être le groupe le
plus puissant il faut que nuque
évidemment ce se constituer en tant que
gros vous tombez dans des dans des
considérations
moi je cite us à un autre niveau c'est
de dire à partir du moment où il ya un
fait politique nouveau 90 estime m non
mais non anticipée qui est l'arrivée en
nombre du rassemblement national et on
dira après qui en portent la
responsabilité si vous le voulez bien
ton pas juste faire des comptes et de la
comptabilité de deux sièges mais il faut
afficher puissamment notre union et donc
bien évidemment il ya d'autres moyens de
le faire on pourrait se dire bon on
reste comme on a prévu mais nous nous
pensons nous pensons et donc c'est une
proposition j'entends parler c'est quoi
l'enjeu pour vous bah écoute et qu'elles
ont gelé ya par exemple je vois que
emmanuel macron non seulement après la
déroute électorale qu'il a pris et le
fait que depuis cinq ans il a mis en
scène le rassemblement national il a
favorisé le rassemblement national pour
obtenir son centre en
fonctionnement
dans le fonctionnement l'enjeu c'est que
depuis ce matin vous avez des
responsables de la macro ni je pense à
l'une des première d'entre elle madame
olivia grégoire porte-parole du
gouvernement qui vient expliquer sur les
plateaux de télé que eh bien oui
normalement la commission des finances
par exemple à l'assemblée revient à
l'opposition et que donc il est normal
qu'elle revienne au rassemblement
national air mais cette fois au
rassemblement national s'il vous plaît
parce que la première force d'opposition
à cette assemblée tels que constituée
sous nos yeux c'est bien la nouvelle
union populaire écologique et sociale
qui n'est pas un coup de com nous ne
sommes pas réunis pour faire un tract
nous avons créé les conditions de
pouvoir gouverner ensemble donc l'idée
c'est bien tant nous soyons cette
première force à l'assemblée par exemple
c'est intéressant et donc attendait
parce que sur la commission des finances
un peu technique est compliqué bien que
les moniteurs la chaîne parlementaire
connaissent mais pourquoi il revient de
droit à la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale selon la tradition
le poste de la présidence de la
commission des finances pourquoi
traditionnellement les commissaires aux
finances vote entre eux au sein de la
commission pour élire leur président est
traditionnellement ce poste revient à
l'opposition raison pour laquelle
normalement la majorité ne participe pas
su r n a plus de députés que vous non
c'est là vous vous gagnerez un vous
gagnerez
explique nan mais justement vous est
pardon pardon vous dire que là à
l'instant vous expliquer mal et que vous
gagneriez peut-être à écouter le mon
raisonnement jusqu'au bout vous êtes
dans la commission des finances il
parlait ça mais c'est pas une leçon
j'essaie de vous expliquer je veux
m'assurer que tout le monde prennez
compris vous dans la commission a dit
attendant la commission dans la
commission des finances d'accord vous
avez la proportion est reine vous avez
les différentes composantes de la
nouvelle union populaire vous convenez
que au sein de cette commission la
nouvelle union populaire sera plus de
nombreuses que le rassemblement national
sommes nous d'accord
oui voilà vous aviez dit une sauf que là
notamment que la nuque aura un candidat
commun la nuit pour un dernièrement à ce
poste alors je veux bien qu'on a compris
joe cole a compris simplement pardon est
ce que les autres partis qui vous ont
dit non tout sinon à quoi bon candidat
la commission oui non ils ne sont pas
d'accord pour que la nuque entente elles
constituent un groupe dans lequel
finalement les parties renonceraient à
leur étiquette c'est ça pour la
difficulté c est ce qu'ils sont ce
qu'ils peuvent se fondre dans la nuque
en tant que groupe à l'assemblée ils ont
dit non très franchement d'abord vous
dites ils ont dit non j'observe que
certains ont dit non mais vous voyez y
compris qu'au sein de ces différentes
organisations certains responsables
aient compris des élus depuis hier soit
ont affiché l'idée que c'était une bonne
idée moi je veux rassurer tout le monde
non attendez vous avait prévenus ou pas
j'ai pas très bien compris mais c'est
une proposition
avant que jean luc mélenchon est la
preuve luc mélenchon tout à l'heure on a
discuté avec nous arriver au siège il
est interrogé par vos collègues qui se
trouvaient devant le siège ils formulent
une proposition je veux dire tout de
suite les grands mots lannux divise non
heymans
de position
mais je veux pas le paquet de crispation
normalement la répète depuis depuis
l'endroit où je me trouve je m'adresse
davantage aux gens qui nous écoutent et
aux auditeurs et aux états majors
politiques mais je veux rassurer tout le
monde sur le fait que pour nous il n'est
aucunement question de dissoudre ou de
fondre les organisations de politique
dans la nouvelle union populaire c'est
juste une question comment est-ce
qu'elle serait ou l'étiquette parce que
si vous n'avez pas de groupe vous n'avez
pas de moyens de fonctionner vous
dépendrait du bon vouloir de nuque ou
d'inde j'ai l'union populaire elle
appartient à toutes celles et ceux qui
la composent donc il ya une personne
vassalise quelqu'un je veux dire là
dedans non simplement ce qu'on pourrait
imaginer si on se dit en effet je ne dis
pas que cet acte est à cette heure c'est
une discussion vaut former l'opposition
si on se dit que c'est la meilleure
manière de fonctionner au sein de
l'assemblée nationale on pourrait très
bien imaginer que chacun garde la
capacité à fonctionner en délégation
écologistes socialistes commune c'est ce
qu'a proposé votre consoeur
collaboratrice de l'élu mathilde
panneaux on va le voir d'ailleurs c'est
assez explicite dans le tweet d'ailleurs
elle n'a pas pris la main tendue dios il
faut trouver collectivement les
conditions je suis favorable à une
présidence tournante bien sûr de façon
ce cas pas d'hégémonie à la grogne dans
le groupe de la france insoumise et un
maintien des délégations par formation
politique c'est-à-dire délégation c'est
un peu comme ça se passe au parlement
européen vous savez il ya des groupes
par exemple agout et groupes de la
gauche puis à l'intérieur il ya
plusieurs composantes ça à peu près la
même idée mais c'est une proposition
d'organisation ce que je pense que je
voudrais entendre
n'abandonnez pas l'idée de convaincre
vos partenaires comme vous la forme pour
former la nuque personne bien sûr mais
ce mais je veux aussi dire c'est que je
comprends qu'au lendemain de ces
élections y ait besoin de choses pour
alimenter médiatiquement mais ce que
veut dire c'est que ont formulé une
proposition l'organisation est tout de
suite j'entends parler de quoi de
divisions au sein de la nouvelle union
menant dans tous les cas soyez rassurés
je passe ça vous rassure vous
personnellement mais la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale
fonctionnera de toute façon comme
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale ce bloc de 150 parlementaires au
moins au sein de l'assemblée nationale
alors après quelle forme ça prendra
est-ce qu'on arrivera à convaincre nos
partenaires parce que nous pensons que
ce serait la meilleure forme
d'organisation et que chacun pourrait
s'y retrouver voyez la preuve dit la
proposition de mathilde de panneaux une
présidence tournante de délégation pour
chacun le but n'est d'écraser personne a
le but est d'être en réaction prend à la
hauteur des événements face à un groupe
du rassemblement
luc mélenchon qui est toujours très
inventif créatif et tactique eh bien il
s'est dit voilà comment on peut garder
effectivement la puissance de notre
force d'opposition notre dynamique je
comprend mais était ce la meilleure
façon je vous le demande parce que il
ressort et vous ressortez collectivement
l'objectif est pas complètement atteint
mais quand même presque 150 députés
c'est puissant c'est important ce qui
n'a pas de gâcher un peu la fête par une
proposition qui est immédiatement
rejetée par des partenaires qui en fait
votre puissance et hier c'est une souche
mans est ce qu'il n'est pas allé trop
vite c'est une belle proposition ils
avaient entre opposition et
non mais ça c'est le savez ça c'est le
temps de la vie médiatique où vous
considérez toujours dire non mais
attendez n'était pas il n'était pas
obligé de même match mais la partie est
bien dans ce cas là vos collègues ne
t'es pas obligé de lui tendre le micro à
ce moment là avait demandé des nouvelles
n'ont jamais supporté qu'elle est
toujours contente de ça vous l'avez dit
en introduction de votre émission nous
avons sous les yeux une situation
politique inédite tout le monde en
convient pas supporté qu'on réfléchisse
et compta tonnes sur la meilleure
manière de nous organiser pour faire ce
que nous avons à faire désormais c'est à
dire faire en sorte de nous opposer au
projet de monsieur macron même si à
cette heure il n'a pas la majorité pour
le mener à bien et puis on en n'a pas
encore dit un mot mais moi je veux dire
je pense d'abord à toutes celles et ceux
qui ont besoin de l'augmentation du smic
on n'a pas encore parlé de fond et un
besoin en juguler l'inflation et à
traduire en arriver là ces questions à
parler du fond mais pour clore ce
chapitre est ce vous n'abandonnez pas
cette proposition non soir non bien sûr
et je vais mettre nos partenaires si le
montant de ce que je comprends que c'est
plutôt un gouffre et me faire parler
parce que je suis pas sûr tout ça
passionne les gens qui nous regardent
mais je veux faire comprendre à nos
partenaires que c'est une proposition
qu'elle se discute et que si nous la
posons dans la discussion aujourd'hui
c'est parce que la situation de ce matin
est nouvelle et notamment du fait de la
force du rassemblement national et je me
permets de le dire pour faire aussi un
peu de politique et pas juste de la
comptabilité dire aussi que le
rassemblement national à 90 députés à
l'assemblée nationale c'est la
responsabilité d'emmanuel macron qui
pendant cinq ans a oeuvré à cette montée
qui a obtenu son duel à la
présidentielle et qui d'ailleurs dans
cette campagne des législatives dans
l'entre-deux tours regardez le nombre de
duels qui impliquait le rassemblement
national et observé comme emmanuel
macron et les siens ont été incapables
une position claire madame bornes quand
elle a ouvert la bouche pour dire ce
qu'il fallait faire en canet avec la
donne est la même personne n'est
à même consigne que jean luc mélenchon
absolument pas non à la martyre où je ne
vous laisserai pas dire sa part
dont ils n'ont pas dit pas une voie pour
le rassemblement national partout
écoutez j'ai compté quelques par exemple
60 duel entre la nouvelle union
populaire et le rassemblement national
et il est faux de dire que dans les 60 k
la macro ni à une parole claire car de
qualité
est-ce que votre ce
que vous mentez relever de manière
systématique soit pas aboutir non mais
si vous voulez donnez moi un qcm
je prends mon stylo je coche vos cases
et je vous rends la copie vous la lisez
avec c'est un échange mais juste
radicalité n'a pas aussi fait peur à ses
électeurs qu effectivement 72 pourtant
cédé 72 % des électeurs macro nice
devrait d'après ipsos n'ont pas choisi
entre un candidat fn et un candidat
nuque est-ce que c'est pas aussi vous
qui avez fait un peu peur à cet électeur
là je ne crois pas vous savez notre
projet politique qui répond simplement à
l'urgence du moment à l'urgence sociale
au fait qu'on est dans un pays qui est
très riche mais qui a 10 millions de
personnes sous le seuil de pauvreté vous
le savez des gens qui payent leur
carburant joli 2 euros à la pompe ça
représente un budget je veux dire y'a
rien dans ce programme qui ne fasse
autre chose que de répondre aux grands
défis qui sont devant nous et de la
manière la plus nécessaire qu'il soit et
la plus utile qu'il soit voilà c'est
tout non en revanche il ya des digues
ont sauté c'est très clair mais depuis
cinq ans emmanuel macron a fait quelques
clins d'oeil il a joué avec le feu il a
fait monter leur assemblée nationale et
puis disons les choses de manière aussi
plus on élargit sont encore la focale
politiquement le rassemblement national
l'extrême droite dans ce pays prospère
sur les débris du néolibéralisme et de
ses dégâts depuis 39 42 % eh bien oui à
la présidentielle n'est pas totalement
absurde qu'elle est 89 députés à
l'assemblée non bien sûr personne ne
l'avait anticipé mais vous avez raison
personne n'ignore la personne personne
ne peut prétendre ignorer depuis des
années en le rassemblement national
prospère et qu'ils prospèrent d'autant
plus sur les débris la déroute du
néolibéralisme qui sème partout la
misère sociale et vous me donnez
l'occasion de m'adresser une nouvelle
fois à celles et ceux qui m'aiment
jusque hier sont allés faire le choix du
rassemblement national je leur dis si
vous votez pour le rassemblement
national en pensant que madame le pen et
ses amis vont s'occuper de vous sur la
question du pouvoir d'achat ce n'est pas
vrai regardez son programme madame le
pen ne propose pas le blocage des prix
elle ne propose pas l'augmentation des
salaires vous êtes bien placés ici à la
chaîne parlementaire pour savoir que par
exemple dans le débat sur les retraites
dans le quinquennat précédent fait pas
madame le pen était absente 120 dont on
parle et vous allez voir c'est une
opposition de pacotille voilà il faut le
dire une opposition de pâques a bien sûr
ses dix tomes traduits abrégée de
boucher rentrer dans le studio ils vont
vous interroger sur beaucoup de points
dont évidemment le fond mais d'abord on
rejoint vincent roux en direct du figaro
bonsoir vincent
bonsoir vous avez une question pour un
loyer de 4,9 vous écoute vous voyez
adrien 4,9 d'abord bravo pour votre
réélection
une question qui lui vient à l'esprit
parce que c'est un point qui est venu en
tous les cas beaucoup pour expliquer le
résultat d'hier et en particulier la
performance du rassemblement national ce
sont les événements qui se sont passés
au stade de france le sénat a est en
train de mener une enquête parlementaire
sur la question est ce que vous vous
allez demander en plus de la motion de
censure
une commission d'enquêté parlementaire
sur ces événements pour déterminer les
vraies responsabilités
écoutez on va voir par quel moyen nous
le faisons en tout cas c'est
incontestable qu'il nous faut la lumière
là dessus et plus globalement sur les
tripatouillages du ministère de
l'intérieur dans les faits qui lui sont
reprochés monsieur darmanin par exemple
vous a inventé je ne sais pas combien de
dizaines de milliers de faux billets
pour le match alors qu'on a pu vérifier
que ça n'était pas le cas mais dans une
autre mesure aussi je veux dire que par
exemple dans l'organisation des
élections vous avez vu que nous avons dû
mener une bataille déterminée au conseil
d'état pour obtenir du ministère dans
les stades de france au stade de france
vous êtes sur le stade de france mais
moi je suis sur le ministère de
l'intérieur d'accord et donc le stade de
france sera pas question je vous ai
répondu oui sur le stade de france je
voulais qu'on fasse une émission sur 7
de france où il ce qui s'est passé est
intolérable
oui la responsabilité en incombe à ce
pouvoir et au fait que depuis longtemps
le couple d'un manin l'allemand
s'agissant du préfet n'est plus capable
d'organiser quelques événements que ce
soit sans que ce soit le désordre voilà
emmanuel macron qui prétend incarner
l'ordre à tous points de vue et supporté
que sur une question précise de stade de
france je puisse avoir un diagnostic
politique élargie à tous points de vue
emmanuel macron incarne le désordre dans
ce pays regardez par exemple la
situation à l'hôpital dont on va parler
de ses comptes par l'éclat du stade de
france mais par la zone qui précise est
ce que vous demandez une commune
ouverture en croit un vincent cette
évolution
il a demandé une commission d'enquêté
pour faire toute la lumière sur ce qui
s'est passé et spécialement sur les
mensonges du ministère de l'intérieur
donc ça sera peut-être merci steve
lorsque vous serez installé à
l'assemblée tomes traduits et roger
boucher sont en face de vous mesdames
c'est tabou bonsoir adrien qadisha alors
est-il confirmé que vous allez déposer
une motion de censure le 5 juillet
prochain le 5 juillet c'est le jour du
discours de politique générale nous
allons en discuter au sein de la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale je sais qu'à moins de 24 heures
vous voulez toutes les réponses mais
voyons c'est même pas encore rencontré
tandis que chez les filles on a entendu
certains qui ont dit oui on va déposer
une motion de censure et c'est vrai que
par exemple ces tuiles des socialistes
c'est une idée tout cas ça sera semblait
déjà falloir qu'on se réunisse et comme
on discute je vais même vous dire vu la
composition de l'assemblée nationale il
n'est même pas sûr qu'il ya une motion
de censure pour empêcher le gouvernement
puisque monsieur macron la même avec ses
alliés pas de majorité je rappelle que
ben arfa en 2010 est tout seul sur
l'étiquette de la république en marche
sans ses alliés il avait une large
majorité absolue de 316 parlementaires
qu'aujourd'hui avec toute la martingale
qui s'appelle désormais je sais plus
d'ailleurs ensemble il n'a même pas de
majorité et vous fait hésiter c'est le
fait que il y aura peut-être même pas
besoin de mon apparence il n'y a pas
d'hésitation d'un vote de confiance que
vous voulez que tout de suite là alors
que l'élection n'a pas 24 heures je
puisse vous répondre sur ce qu'on va
faire le 5 juillet à l'assemblée sont
déjà prononcés et donc et donc parce que
nous n'avons pas pu encore nous réunir
pour en discuter si certains disent ah
ben moi je pense faire autrement vous
avez forcément un vote de confiance de
là la première ministre après son
discours de politique tout dépend quel
est le contenu mais je crois qu'il est
absolument invraisemblable que
d'ailleurs madame bandes puissent se
maintenir en l'état et moi je vais même
vous dire ce que j'en pense je pense
qu'à pas besoin d'attendre de 5 juillet
pour ça que les urnes viennent de parler
hier soir et que c'est un échec cinglant
pour être venus
eh bien ça change que on est dans une
situation de crise politique
donc un moment donné nous par exemple je
le dis nous restons disponibles pour
gouverner le pays
la majorité il a quand même une majorité
restreinte il a quand même une majorité
qu'est ce que ça change alors on
aimerait bien d'autres qui est il ya une
majorité tout va bien on change de
gouverneur est bande pour qui mais
écoutez pour qui nous avons une
situation de blocage politique et
vraisemblablement cela pourrait durer si
emmanuel macron n'est pas en état de
gouverner c'est à lui aussi d'en tirer
des conclusions et dont je dirais perdu
ces élections d'acord donc tout va bien
non mais sa majorité relative michel
rocard a gouverné avec alors donc a pas
de problème va pouvoir gouverner nous à
pouvoir se poser normalement mais c'est
parce que vous racontez depuis 24 heures
vous dit que ça va être ingouvernable
que ça va être bloquée donc moi comme
responsable politique je vous dis nous
avons fait une campagne pour gouverner
le pays vous voulez me faire dire qu'on
l'a perdu je le reconnais nous ne sommes
pas majoritaires nous avions
suffisamment de second tour et
d'ailleurs nous étions la seule force
politique capable de ça par exemple hier
voter rassemblement national pour celles
et ceux qui l'ont fait avec l'utilité
d'offrir à madame le pen un groupe
parlementaire elle est très contente
c'est un cadeau que certains lui ont
fait mais du point de vue de la capacité
à bâtir une autre majorité à renverser
le pouvoir macro nist l'effet était de
zéro puisque madame le pen n'était pas
qualifié dans un nombre suffisant de
second tour de toutes les façons pour
faire une autre majorité n'évolue
électeurs de la france est d'environ
2100 vous me dites désormais vous dites
aidant même si elle doit faire quoi
faire mais pour l'instant celui qui doit
se poser la question de quoi faire ils
étaient l'elysée c'était manuel macron à
lui de se débrouiller d'une situation
dont il est essentiellement responsables
pour le reste je les décisions à prendre
ce que je dis pour envoyer un signal que
je dis en tout cas madame martichoux
c'est que il peut pas y avoir deux
déroutes électorales aussi spectaculaire
que celle d'hier soir pour emmanuel
macron son qu'il n'y a absolument rien
qui faisait de significatif dans son
vous diriez quoi il est aveugle ou sourd
et n'entend rien il nous a plutôt
habitués à ça et emmanuel macron c'est à
dire il a été habitué à une assemblée
dans laquelle il avait les presse bouton
de la république en marche où tout
allait bien on finalement c'était
l'imprimante de l'elysée ça ne sera plus
pareil et donc soit il est capable de
composer pour appliquer son programme
auquel cas nous devrons nous y opposer
mais si c'est impossible et moi je le
redis même si ces élections n'ont pas
été gagnée pour nous eh bien nous sommes
disposés et le moment venu nous
gouvernerons ce pays moi je vais vous
dire une chose diagnostic que je pose
sur la situation c'est que la révolution
citoyenne que nous avons théorisé avec
jean luc mélenchon elle est enclenchée
depuis longtemps depuis plusieurs années
mais c'est parce que
c'est pas terminé je dis pas qu'elle est
réglé écoutez moi je vous dis que ce
processus de révolution citoyenne il est
engagé et que à chaque fois qu'il ya des
échéances électorales nationales nous
nous rapprochons de l'objectif
systématiquement et donc inéluctablement
ça va finir par arriver le
néolibéralisme qu'incarne emmanuel
macron aller
je veux dire c'est faire remarquer que
vous vous et je comprends vous analysez
la vie politique au travers des jeux
d'alliances des rapports de force au
sein
non
je vous dis c'est que madame dati
choquant je vous réponds nombre de
députés petite étiquette désaccord entre
nous ça vous convient et ça correspond à
votre réponse quand je vous dis que le
processus de révolution citoyenne et
c'est moi terminer est engagé et que
c'est un processus qui va se poursuivre
ça a l'air de pas vous parler du tout
parce qu'on dirait que l'on prenne à la
danse raconte des choses auréole les
français ont compris que la gauche était
arrivé à ma force à l'âge de 64 députés
en 2017 à sont néanmoins le se demande
comment la gouverner et on vous demande
à vous comment faire en sorte de la
gouverne on
ne peut pas leur année on ne peut pas la
gouverner pour faire ma retraite à 65
ans on ne paie pas on ne peut pas la
gouverner pour faire le travail contre
en contrepartie du rsa on ne peut pas la
gouverner pour faire 80 milliards
d'économies que monsieur macron si
ça vous intéresse pas alors si justement
des gens malhonnêtes ont partagé par
cette intention juste moi arrêtez de
m'interrompre dans ce cas madame martine
ans on échangeait dit bah alors arrêtez
de m'interrompre moi je ne vous en
feront pas d'ombré à catena salle et on
va continuer quel d'opposition
comptez-vous pratiqué pendant ce
prochain quinquennat est ce que vous
allez être dans l'obstruction à ce que
l'idée c'est de bloquer tous les textes
qui émane de la majorité commencent
alors n avons jamais aidés et nous ne
saurons jamais dans une opposition
principe yale ce n'est pas parce que
c'est emmanuel macron qui le dit que
c'est nécessairement mal même si pour
l'instant tout ce qu'il raconte ne
paraît pas convenir à la situation
politique sociale écologique
démocratique j'ai le souvenir que sur la
réforme des retraites vous aviez déposé
dix neuf mille amendements ce qui est en
soi de l'obstruction et vous avez
normalement davantage de souvenirs
parlementaire que moi pour savoir que
une obstruction avec le nom d'amendement
que vous citez c'est une obstruction
très petit bras c'est quand même et que
vous avez vécu des heures d'obstruction
à l'assemblée c'est arrivé mais c'est
quand même une obstruction alors note
alors je vous réponds la question
n'était pas de savoir si nous n'allions
jamais pratiqué l'obstruction mais si sa
lettre tout le temps comme ça je vous
réponds moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est pas
ce qui se passe dans l'hémicycle c'est
le sort des gens à l'extérieur qui
dépendent de ce qui est décidé à
l'intérieur et donc si ce qui est décidé
à l'intérieur va dans le bon sens si
monsieur macron demain frappé par la
grâce venez vous dirai pas écouté j'ai
entendu les urnes et même si je ne suis
pas majoritaire l'augmentation du smic à
1500 euros pour tous les gens qui ont
besoin on va la faire quelles raisons
aurions nous de nous y opposer je ne
crois pas que ce sera offert dans le
pays puisque sinon vous êtes élu quelles
sont les idées donc majoritaires dans le
pays madame vous n'arrivez pas actives
qui est sorti dans la lecture politique
du pays depuis le 10 avril même dans des
institutions conçu et c'est un problème
et c'est là qu'on a un problème
institutionnel de crise politique c'est
que nous avons des institutions calibré
pour organiser la confrontation entre
deux blocs alors que ne vous en déplaise
désormais il n'y a plus de dans le pays
mais trois mêmes au moins un quatrième
avec les abstentionnistes qui à tout
moment et c'est notre tâche de les
convaincre peuvent décider de faire la
bascule pour l'un ces trois blocs voilà
je pense qu'il faut véritablement
entendre que le paysage politique post
10 avril mais plus le paysage politique
d'avant le 10 avril et que ceux qui
comptent beaucoup c'est le sort des gens
voilà et aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un
pays où après cinq ans emmanuel macron
cinq personnes c'est-à-dire une de plus
autour de cette table 5 milliardaire
possède autant que 27 millions de
français et que tout cela prenne des
retraites puisque vous venez de la
border un instant à l'instant est ce que
il ya des textes par exemple la réforme
des retraites sur laquelle vous pourriez
faire une alliance avec le rassemblement
national puisque vous êtes d'accord là
dessus vous refusez la retraite à 64 à
65 ans et vous êtes plutôt sur la
retraite à 60 ou 62 ans alors le
problème et non la manière dont vous
posez votre question pardon c'est pas
une mise en cause du tout c'est juste
quand vous dites alliance avec le front
national on a l'impression qu'on se
retrouverait dans une salle obscure pour
dit les quelque chose je dis je dis est
ce que sur un texte comme les retraites
vous pouvez à des convergences avec
leurs 6 2 je n'ai pas vu que madame le
pen propose la même chose que nous
s'agissant des retraites puisqu'elle a
renoncé à la retraite au droit à la
retraite à 60 ans pour tous mais si le
rassemblement national pierre paul
jacques peu importe comment il s'appelle
est d'accord avec la retraite à 60 ans
que souhaite 76% des français dans un
dernier sondage eh bien nous le ferons
c'est surtout tous d'accord dans
l'opposition et dans le rejet de la
réforme donc ça pourrait être une
alliance un accord qui pourrait
permettre de faire capoter une réforme à
ce que ça vous pourriez leur faire sur
d'autres textes par exemple et peut-être
nous verrons au cas par cas savez vous
êtes vous identifier des otages est
d'accord peut-être une chose qui peut
vous aider à comprendre mon explication
il ya un sondage ifop paru la semaine
dernière ce que vous dites ces idées ne
sont pas majoritaires c'est la
différence entre la réalité sociale du
pays est ce que les français pensent et
ce qui sort des urnes dans des
institutions qui sont calibrés pour par
exemple le scrutin uninominal à deux
tours etc sauf que là on a quasiment la
proportionnelle et qu'on a un scrutin
majeur est d'accord sauf que ce n'est
pas complètement la proportionnelle tout
le monde l'aura compris mais si demain
il y avait la proportionnelle moi j'y
suis prêt ya pas de problème mais mais
mais donc ce que je veux dire c'est que
la semaine dernière peut-être ça ne vous
intéresse pas non plus vous me le dire
et intérêts moi si ça ce n'est pas
passionnant la semaine dernière ifop a
publié un sondage qui montre que sur les
points principaux du programme de la
nouvelle union populaire c'est-à-dire la
réforme des retraites à 60 ans le smic à
1500 euros le blocage des prix le
rétablissement de lier ce f ces
propositions sont extrêmement
majoritaire est plébiscité par les
français alors vous allez me dire oui
mais là monsieur 4 dans nos sièges là
vous n'êtes pas majoritaires j'ai
entendu
se sont pas déplacés non plus nous
sommes bien d'accord
la sélection le principal défi c'est à
dire que c'est là les plaies non mais je
crois que c'est intéressant ce qu'on se
dit là c'est à dire que les la
l'équation comment on peut faire en
sorte que la ou un programme et deux
fêtes plébiscité par les français quand
les sondeurs appelle les français madame
monsieur vous êtes d'accord avec çà çà
çà çà çà ils disent oui entre a prévu 63
et 80 pour le moment améliorable à ces
propositions maintenant ce qu'il nous
faut c'est en effet convaincre notamment
je le dis les abstentionnistes qui ont
manqué vous avez 25 millions
d'abstentionnistes
si ces gens-là aller voter et c'est à
nous de les convaincre je leur fais pas
la leçon mais je crois que nous serions
large majorité raison j'ai noté qu'il
nous a monté ça fait pour avoir la
majorité relative hier pour avoir la
majorité relative hier on a fait les
calculs il a manqué 16500 quatre voix à
la nouvelle union populaire dans 57
circonscriptions et on aurait eu la
majorité
avaient raison et vous a manqué des voix
n'avait pas plus sans doute convaincu
que d'autres donc ça reste un chantier
non mais on va parler de la chanson
d'améliorer la vie quotidienne des
français puisque c'est ce que vous
voulez et iliad notamment le tec sur le
pouvoir d'achat qui va arriver tout
début juillet plus de pouvoir d'achat
pour les français vous ne pouvez pas ne
pas le voter ce texte c'est incroyable
vous l'avez vu vous le texte bah oui ben
laden est largement vous connaissez
celle du point d'indicé simplement de la
prime macron en valorisation de l'action
des retraites
jlt stablement cigares et il y a
incontestablement là dedans des choses
avec lesquelles nous pouvons être
d'accord mais va falloir voir si une
fois le package complet réunis eh bien
ça fait le poids par rapport à la
situation du pays je vous prends un
exemple vous dites est ce que vous êtes
contre le petit chèque que donne
emmanuel macron dans l'absolu ce petit
chèque qui va même si s'est améliorée
même si cette sortie de prison là
forcément améliorer la situation ben non
pourquoi parce que nous nous prônons
l'idée que ce n'est pas au trésor public
à l'état d'assurer la rendre privé pour
des petits chèques qui sont en plus
insuffisant et les français qui nous
écoutent le savent quand nous proposons
le blocage des prix que faisons nous
quand vous proposons blocage des prix
nous proposons que ce soit charge sur
par exemple les fournisseurs karski
emmanuel macron ne vous dit jamais c'est
que pendant que lui verse d'échecs avec
les fonds du trésor public donc l'argent
des contribuables total le fournisseur
de pétrole vient de réaliser le plus
gros bénéfice jamais réalisé de toute
l'histoire industrielle du pays donc
bloquer les prix au blocage des prix il
va bénéficier quand même aux personnes
riches également en fait il va
bénéficier le montre notre cible est pas
plus les personnes modestes puisque
c'est plutôt vous ces personnes là que
vous voulez aider en particulier mais
nous avons des dispositions dans le
programme qui sont vers les personnes
les plus modestes comme le blocage des
prisons
vous allez aider les cinq personnes qui
qui est de couvrir auquel vous faisait
référence tout à l'heure a qui gagnent
des milliards mais vous savez nous avons
dans le programme des dispositions qui
ne font pas le tri en effet entre les
gens je prends un autre exemple vous
savez que nous proposons les premiers
mètres cubes d'eau gratuits parce que
l'eau est nécessaire à tout le monde que
vous soyez riche ou pauvre nous
proposons qu'ils soient gratuites pour
tout le monde par exemple voilà et des
dispositions de ce type dans le
programme par contient aussi des mesures
fiscales par exemple la réforme fiscale
à quatorze tranches d'impôt qui font que
celles et ceux qui gagnent moins de 4000
euros vont payer moins mais que par
contre les très riches ce que monsieur
macron a beaucoup servi pendant cinq ans
vont payer davantage voilà il ya des
propositions qui sont en effet
redistributive et on a d'autres qui sont
universels parce que ce sont des princes
dans
le texte pouvoir d'achat d'abord
supporter un que nous lisent 2 que nous
nous fassions idée de chacune des
propositions qu au cas par cas nous
voyons si nous sommes d'accord avec j'ai
dit qu'on ne ferait pas d'opposition
principe yale si le compte y est on
verra si le compte n'y est pas beau ça
que les français ils retiendront que
vous n'avez pas voulu voter ce chèque
même si lille est ce de la même manière
de la même manière que sur certaines
lois qui sont passés plus récemment
comme par exemple le ségur et les lois
sur la santé nous avons voté contre et
monsieur véranda dira vous n'avez pas
accepter la petite fille est alors qu'à
côté il ya la montagne qui n'est pas
réalisé est entendu par les soignants
si vous votez pas mais vous c'est pas du
tout le même
17la vous allez être très bien et ça
peut faire complètement capoté revient à
l'aller bien vite et nous verrons en
toute hypothèse ce qui nous intéresse
c'est l'intérêt général et le sort des
gens qui se trouvent à l'être lecteurs
de l'assemblée et qui ont besoin de ces
changements ce qui va dans le bon sens
pour améliorer la vie des gens on n'a
pas de raison de s'y opposer s'ils sont
nés bien présente le bloquer vous le
dites ce soir mais ça dépend mais ne
vous laissez dont les propositions si
vous estimez que ça n'ait pas su mais
vous allez estimé ça n'est pas suffisant
puisque vraisemblablement il ya une
sorte vos revendications
risques je pense sauf si jean luc
mélenchon est à matignon d'ici là de ne
pas être dans le texte donc qu'est ce
que vous ferez ce moment là est ce que
vous aiderez quand même le texte a passé
vous prendrait le risque qu'elles soient
bloqués parce qu'il ya une majorité trop
trop près troyes nous verrons si c'est
un texte prend un exemple c'est un texte
qui propose des petits chèques
insuffisant très aléatoire alors qu'il
ya des mesures simples claires peut être
radical mais utiles à prendre eh bien
nous verrons au cas par cas voilà pas
vous dire avant j'ai pas lu le texte je
peux pas me prononcer aujourd'hui notre
texte qui auriez par exemple pardon
c'est encore du fonds excusez-moi
emmanuel marrant il est encore pour
quelques jours président de l'union
européenne à quoi aura servi cette
présidence monsieur macro aurait pu sur
l'essence par exemple proposé aux
partenaires européens de bloquer les
prix ensemble parce qu'aucun fournisseur
n'aurait été capable de refuser un
marché de 450 millions de personnes il
ne l'a pas fait pourquoi en attendant
les gens ils leur sujet sireuil sur
l'ukraine jarret mais pendant ce temps
c'est pas un petit sujet les gens qui
payent 2 euros le litre d'essence à la
pompe
je dois débourser magnifique que vous
avez l'air d'adorer et que vous vous
voteriez d'ailleurs particulièrement non
dans cette ascension attendons mais vous
en faites bien là
non
je n'ai pas vu un gars n'a pas d'autres
alors il ya un autre texte sur la
planification écologique alors ça c'est
vraiment votre sujet c'est quelque chose
que j'ai un rythme et donc vous allez
voter pendant la campagne non mais est
ce que vous trouvez que ça va dans le
bon sens - ac emmanuel macron reprenne
notre notre vocabulaire oui parce que à
force de reprendre notre vocabulaire
peut-être en europe leur at-il le
contenu mais encore une fois nous avons
un programme nous sommes forts de cela
et nous allons faire des propositions
très franchement pardon on va être plus
nombreux que la fois dernière mais vous
nous avez vu y compris faire beaucoup de
propositions vous avez vu que le groupe
1 soumis à l'assemblée nationale ces
cinq dernières années avait beaucoup
proposé oui vous pouvez pas dire rien a
été votée pourquoi parce qu'ils ne l'ont
pas voter c'est vrai vous avez raison il
aurait dû voter certains manèges et vous
n'avez pas non plus cherché à bien sûr
que si nous avons passé des rdd mai mais
vous avez raison madame je suis d'accord
avec vous emmanuel macron et ses
parlementaires aurait dû voter des
propositions de la france en soumise
c'est le sens de ce que vous dites et
j'en suis d'accord ils sont
radiés il faut dire que souvent la
république en marche a fait de
l'opposition de principe aux
propositions de la france insoumise j'en
suis d'accord alors pourtant ça aurait
amélioré le sort des gens pas être
planification écologique comment est ce
que vous allez vous mettre d'accord avec
l'ensemble de la nuque sur des sujets
comme par exemple on le sait des sujets
qu'il ya des vraies différences comme le
nucléaire vont aussi parler de l'otan
peut parler aussi de l'utilisation du
terme de violences policières et un
certain nombre de sujets sur laquelle il
ya des vrais désaccords entre les
différentes composantes de la nuque je
parlerai pas de désaccord mais de
nuances parce que on s'est retrouvé avec
un programme bach étages et de
gouvernement sur le nucléaire vous êtes
quand même pas d'accord il ya entre les
communes oui la façade c'est vrai c'est
vrai il ya une il ya une composante en
effet parti communiste qui est plutôt
promotrice du nucléaire eh bien vous
savez sur 650 mesure il ya aller 5 % du
programme y en a 33 c 5 % voilà
effectivement mais quand vous faites
dans ces 5 % sur ces 30 j'étais en train
de vous répondre donc il y en a en effet
5% et donc dans ces cas là eh bien c'est
la sagesse parlementaire qui tranchera
je crois d'ailleurs que la situation
qu'on a sous les yeux c'est aussi un
moment de reparler tahar isation de
notre vie politique en effet c'est sûr
et c'est pourquoi à mon avis si la
chaîne parlementaire vous n'allez pas
vous ennuyer pas que vous l'ayez déjà
fait dans le quinquennat précédent mais
là c'est clair que l'assemblée va jouer
un tout autre rôle que le rôle qu'elle a
joué les cinq dernières années et donc
liberté de vote bien sûr mais d'ailleurs
ça c'est dans votre accord elle est
convenu cette liberté de vote et puis
bon supporter que normalement le débat
parlementaire doit servir à se
convaincre aussi à échanger des
arguments si nous arrivons à l'avance
comme vous nous le demander avant que le
débat ait lieu avec des positions déjà
acquise on pourrait faire l'économie des
débats à l'assemblée nationale dans ce
cas autant qu'on cherche a essayé de se
convaincre par les changes d'arguments
ça me paraît intéressant c'est ça l'art
parlementarisation de la vie politique
aussi du coup à quoi sert dans ce
contexte l'éventualité d'un intergroupe
puisque en gros il y aura les mesures
sur lesquelles vous êtes déjà d'accord
depuis les mesures sur lesquelles vous
n'êtes pas d'accord il ya la liberté la
liberté de vote donc l'intergroupe
qu'est-ce qui coordonne par
l'intergroupe dans ce cas là il peut
servir à essayer de tenter d'harmoniser
nos positions sur les points ces
discussions où c'est pour faire des
propositions de groupes et bien par la
discussion il se pourrait très bien
qu'on arrive à se convaincre les uns les
autres voyez-vous il comprit y compris
sur le nucléaire par exemple il ya des
arguments échangés voyez j'en cite qu'un
seul pour vous citer un exemple sur le
nucléaire parce qu'on pourrait plus
longues sur le nucléaire mais juste par
exemple souvent il nous est opposé
l'idée que l'énergie nucléaire a
l'avantagé contrairement à certaines
sources renouvelables de ne pas être
intermittente c'est un argument qui est
souvent posée par les promoteurs du
nucléaire vous aura pas échappé qu'avec
le réchauffement climatique et des
études de canicule qu'on a si l'énergie
nucléaire devient intermittente parce
que les cours d'eau s'assèchent et parce
qu'on a plus l'eau nécessaire pour
refroidir parfois certains acteurs qui
sont à l'arrêt bon ça c'est de l'
échange d'arguments on va l'avoir mais
le plus important ce que là vous
insistez beaucoup sur ces 5 % de nuances
le plus important c'est que nous sommes
la seule force politique tient à vous
poser des questions l'homme était
capable de faire un programme partagé
pardon mais au sein du groupe composite
ensemble de la majorité il ya des points
de désaccord bien plus important j'ai
entendu edouard philippe dire qu'il
était pour la retraite à 67 ans monsieur
macron 65 j'ai entendu par exemple le
modem être en promotion de la
proportionnelle mais le groupe ma
chronique le refusé précédemment bref
vous voyez bien que dans cette majorité
tout le monde n'est pas d'accord nous on
a un avantage c'est tout est transparent
il ya un programme de 650 mesures sur
lesquelles nous sommes d'accord il ya
quelques points sur lesquels la
discussion doit se poursuivre et puis
c'est l'honneur de l'assemblée je crois
alors il ya trois ministres qui ont été
battus hier adrien catena ce qui oblige
à un remaniement selon la règle d'usagé
en vigueur est-ce que vous pensez que ce
remaniement il doit être un petit peu
plus large ben contestable le mans je
crois qu'au delà du fait que si ces
remaniements pour remplacer celle des
sous compactes et précis c'est pas
suffisant moi je crois qu'il faut un
remaniement plus large en tout cas je
crois clairement que ce dispositif
gouvernemental ne peut pas tenir alors à
quoi il ressemblerait ce remaniement
plus large ça veut dire quoi intégré par
exemple delphi vous seriez pas ça dépend
pour mener quel politique n'est en fait
le plus difficile pour l'instant c'est
qu emmanuel macron lui-même n'a pas
l'air de bien savoir quelle politique il
veut mener vous le savez vous parce que
nous avons un programme complet vous
pouvez le discuter nous dire vous n'êtes
pas d'accord sur ça vous discutez vous
connaissez le programmes des manuels
macron je veux dire à part le elle après
avoir le petit feuillet présidentielle
lui demander de sang de tautologie bah
écoutez je crois en tout cas clairement
que emmanuel macron qui était droit dans
ses bottes clairement hier soir on lui a
retiré ses bottes
kouamatien emmanuel macron
frais le présenter à un public qu'on vit
demain et après demain à l'elysée les
forces politiques ayant vocation à
constituer un groupe à l'assemblée
nationale ça vous concerne d'accord vous
irait honorer l'invitation sais pas
pourquoi nous invitent ils m'ont est
toujours disposé à discuter on a déjà
participé à des discussions était de
savoir publiquement gouverner ensemble
dans ce contexte bas il va falloir qu'il
change radicalement son programme dans
ce cas là est si vous aviez il vous y
allez la main est tendue en tout cas
avant qu ils nous tendent la main pour
une réunion à l'elysée je pense qu'il
serait peut-être plus important qui
clarifie ses intentions politiques
voulaient demander de prendre encore en
vie je n'ai pas apprécié et je n'ai pas
envie d'aider un président de la
république élu au mois d'avril sur un
des éléments de propositions qui me
paraissait être d'une brutalité sociale
sans nom à obtenir une majorité l'un
aspire monsieur macron pas plus tard
qu'à quelques jours sur le tarmac avec
l'avion derrière demandé une majorité
aux français pourquoi pas laisser
pourrir la vie 50 elle souhaite
participer à un gouvernement d'union
nationale via le web échanger dans
l'intérêt supérieur national de la
nation c'est ça on sait que si emmanuel
macron avait obtenu une majorité
relative plus importante où une majorité
absolue hier il aurait convié à une
discussion interne et non les
cp un gouvernement d'union nationale en
soit c'est l'objet non pas pour
appliquer la politique d' emmanuel
macron tel qu'il l'a dit mais pour se
mettre d'accord sur un autre péché
comment est ce que c'est possible si les
manuels envie de reprendre à son compte
le programme de la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale la
mairie de sutil fait un pas vers vous
est ce que vous êtes vers lui pardon
mais vous me demandez ça aujourd'hui sur
la base d'un
pas sur quelles bases convoque t-il pour
discuter de quoi qu at il l'intention de
changer quelqu'un et ça n'a rien
d'extravagant
république parle avec les acteurs
politiques qui va les 10 éléments qui
voulait dit donc la question n'allons
pas faire il faut sauver le soldat
macron dans
vous allez d'abord en parler avait
d'abord on parlait pas qu'avec jean luc
mélenchon avec nos partenaires
là bas je ne sais pas nous allons en
discuter je vous me prenez là au
dépourvu si je dis quelque chose qui est
mon avis personnel est que dans une
heure l'un d'eux nous dit quelque chose
de différent vous allez faire les gros
titres sur les désaccords indépassable
au sein
vous en avez un gros sur la patate en ce
qui nous concerne nous thébaux lisez à
chaque occasion non je vous dis à vous
lis pas non madame martichoux vous
diabolise pas je vous dis simplement que
tout à l'heure jean luc mélenchon fait
une proposition une proposition et puis
que tout de suite c'est des désaccords
n'ont n'y a pas de désaccord mais duval
et ricky tweet immédiatement pour dire
je ne veux pas participer avait pas de
noms communs
le résumé c'est que nous décidons sur la
manière la plus efficace à organiser des
cas comme emmanuel macron visiblement
votre première réaction à cette
information
cette invitation à l'elysée c'est
pourtant la vie car je vois pas quel est
l'intérêt d'une telle enquête
personnellement il ya le cnr le conseil
régional et la refondation qui devait se
tenir là juste après ces élections
législatives c'est visiblement un petit
peu reporté mais vous sur le principe à
ce que vous y participeraient ou pas il
ya eu le grand débat national après les
gilet jaune il ya eu le
comment ça s'appelait déjà la convention
insisté pour le climat où monsieur
macron a dit je reprends tout aura que 3
de joker puis au final c'est que des
joker et reprend les propositions de la
signature entre y en a marre quoi voilà
y en a marre emmanuel macron doit
entendre qu'il n'y a pas de majorité
sociale dans le pays pour appliquer la
politique qu'il souhaite appliquer donc
à voir si les prêts à en changer
radicalement mais je ne le vois pas pour
l'instant faire ce genre de sida est pas
moral de vainqueur ah bon vous trouvez à
écouter pardon mais nous n'avons pas
gagné les élections il ya et de
marquixanes nous sommes déçus du
résultat dans la déception il ya des
succès nous sommes contents de passer de
64 parlementaires à un groupe qui va
rentrer en force à l'assemblée et qui
est la première force d'opposition dans
cet hémicycle mais j'aurais préféré en
effet venir ce soir sur votre plateau
pour vous annoncer ce que nous allions
faire dans un gouvernement et pas pour
nous mêmes pas pour la gloire
personnelle de rentrer dans je ne sais
quel ministère pour tous les gens qui
attendent des changements qui à cette
heure ne les auront pas bah oui mais pas
que moi d'ailleurs et pas que nous bon
bah c'est bien parce que entre hier soir
et cet après midi c'est vrai qu'il y
avait un changement merci merci beaucoup
permettez
je pose une question personnelle
nous pas né aux députés comme d'autres
traînent en bois qui vont vous rejoindre
quelles responsabilités vous
souhaiteriez voir voilà l'assemblée pour
faire profiter votre expérience des
autres incontestablement on va devoir
les pertes ont encadré c'est ce qu'ils
vont nous rejoindre bien sûr et vous
allez voir dès demain arrivée à
l'assemblée je vous le dis des gens que
à mon avis vous allez très vite avoir
envie d'inviter des personnages comme
rachel kéké femme de ménage à l'ibis
batignolles et qui a mené cette lutte et
en appelant des cadres du mouvement sont
ils
on va travailler une organisation la
plus efficace on va voir et y compris on
va voir en fonction des rapports de
force quels sont les différents postes
qui peuvent être attribués on va voir
tout ça est pour moi très franchement à
ce sont vous verrais plutôt envie de
prendre la responsabilité soit dans le
groupe soit dans le fonctionnement même
de l'assemblée
y'a bon et bien pourquoi pas mais il
vaudrait mieux qu'on ait envie
commission mémoire du travail exigeant
mais voyez par exemple ça bon évidemment
ça a son importance mais le plus haut
grâce à vous bien sûr et le plus
important pour moi à 7 heures par
exemple la proposition qu'a formulé jean
luc mélenchon d'un groupe commun me
paraît encore plus enthousiasmante que
de savoir si tel ou tel autre veine je
sais pas vice président de l'assemblée
où caster quoi que ce soit c'est
l'affichage politique ça viendra pour
celles et ceux qui nous font confiance
extraire cette assise en face de vos
directeurs adjoints soir
avec beaucoup d'attention et je vous ai
trouvé plus constructif que
d'avoir la volonté de renverser ce
gouvernement où ce pouvoir mais
peut-être j'ai l'impression
j'ai l'impression quand j'écoute les uns
les autres tous les groupes qui sont des
opposants au président de la république
et sa majorité que personne ne veut
ajouter du chaos au cas où est ce que je
me trompe après ça dépend ce que vous
voulez dire par là yves thréard pour moi
je lui ai dit tout à l'heure j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire pendant une
question le chaos il est dans le pouvoir
actuel je pense ça se vérifie et y
compris à la sortie de ce scrutin
nous ne sommes pas là pour accompagner
emmanuel macron pour l'aider à mener à
bien ces projets qui sont de mauvais
projet voilà qui ne sont pas à la
hauteur je vais 10 des situations
d'urgence qu'on a dans notre pays nous
sommes disposés à appliquer une autre
politique
j'ai envie de vous dire quels que soient
les moyens institutionnels de le faire
voilà et donc nous devons nous porter à
la hauteur de ses responsabilités et
puis y compris se dire que peut être la
situation que nous avons sous les yeux
peut être aussi extrêmement précaires
qui peut dire aujourd'hui au vu de la
situation que nous avons à l'assemblée
nationale que tout cela va durer cinq
ans personne ne le peut donc on est dans
un moment de tâtonnements général et il
faut se tenir prêt à toutes les
hypothèses mais toujours en respectant
le mandat qui nous a été confiée et le
mandat qui nous a été confiée pour ce
qui nous concerne c'est pas d'aidé
emmanuel macron à mener à bien son
projet c'est de s'opposer à lui est en
démocratie tout le monde sait que le
rôle d'opposition il fera son importance
et il est nécessaire et ce que vous
estimez que là nous sommes nous
traversons une crise politique dans la
mesure où il n'y a pas de majorité qui
se dégage
suffisamment fortes pour faire passer
des textes c'est incontestable une crise
politique mais les deux régimes et une
crise internationale je le crois je
pense que ces institutions et ça fait
longtemps que nous le disons
reconnaissait deux ans a fait ça mais de
l'eau à votre moulin quand vous dites
depuis très longtemps que vous devez on
doit passer à une sixième république
évidemment et vous me permettez de
redire ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est que je crois que le processus de
révolution citoyenne il est enclenchée
depuis peut-être cinq ou dix ans et
qu'il est inéluctable que le
néolibéralisme qui a eu cours pendant 30
à 40 ans est en voie de décrépitude que
d'ailleurs l'extrême droite est en
embuscade et monsieur macron sancerre je
l'expliquais et qu' il va y avoir une
issue à tout ça savez jean luc mélenchon
a souvent dit rappelez vous en depuis 10
15 ans il a toujours dit à la fin ça se
terminera entre l'extrême droite et nous
je le crois véritablement et oui nous
vivons un moment de crise politique du
fait notamment que nos institutions je
les dis prévoit une confrontation entre
deux blocs alors que désormais le pays
n'est plus structurée politique de cette
manière ce qui est assez étonnant c'est
que là on a tourné avec un mode de
scrutin qui était un mode de scrutin
majoritaire mais si on avait été dans un
mode de scrutin proportionnel
cette opposition entre
de
votre votre gauche et celle la droite de
madame le pen elle serait encore
supérieur est vous demi ne riez
complètement peut-être le paysage
politique peut-être et peut-être dans ce
cas là ne reviennent que ça sympa plus
souhaitable d'une certaine façon puisque
ça donnerait la part belle à l'extrême
droite indépendante alors je dis que à
16000 voit prendre avait une majorité
relative qui nous aurait sans doute
permis de faire des choses voilà c'est
clair non je pense que la situation me
paraît assez inextricables et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je crois que c'est
notre responsabilité de dire aussi que
nous devons en toute hypothèse à chaque
étape nous tenir prêts glace et les
responsabilités nous y étions préparés
veut dire aujourd'hui la situation a pu
être autre vous avait ironisé ce matin
mais c'est vrai sur le fait que jean luc
mélenchon aurait pu ce matin être en
situation d'être appelé par le président
de la république je veux dire
disons que voilà quand on gagne pas une
élection
tout de même ce qui nous aide à le faire
c'est que
incontestablement si nous n'avions pas
fait la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale rendue possible
par le score de jean luc mélenchon la
présidentielle
la situation pourrait être pire encore
précisément je vais peut-être vous faire
un peu moins plaisir maintenant
bas parce que pour l'instant vous avez
l'impression de me faire plaisir et ça
m'aide gratiné alors de deux
politologues digne de ce nom les hier
soir sur ce plateau qui s'appelle roland
cayrol et pascal perrineau disait en
fait pendant cette campagne des
législatives le meilleur qui a été
longue le meilleur agent électoral de
madame le pen ça a été jean luc
mélenchon parce que il a ceinturé les
écrans il était partout sur tous les
médias et que les gens eh bien ils en
avaient assez et que probablement et si
on regarde des reports de bois si on
regarde les reports de voix les mêmes
légende yeux ensemble ster la majorité
présidentielle entre un candidat
de votre formation ou un candidat et
rennes ils ont plutôt voté et raide
ça me paraît être une analyse à la
petite semaine quand même je vous
explique pourquoi je crois qu'au
contraire même si nous n'avons pas le
résultat escompté c'est vrai ils vont
convient peut-être vergy verser ce que
ce que je veux dire c'est que au
contraire l'action de jean luc mélenchon
dans ces élections législatives
quoi qu'en ait dit ses détracteurs au
premier desquels les maquereaux nist à
redonner du sens à l'élection
législative elle à rappeler par exemple
que l'élection législative
contrairement à la petite musique
entendue est une élection pour la
conquête du pouvoir madame le pen
paradoxalement a commencé cette campagne
en disant de toute façon monsieur macro
aura une majorité on n'y peut rien faire
et donc c'était la grande gagnante de
l'opération ben on
pourquoi mais désarmés parce qu'elles
réalisent 90 députés nous 151 voix hier
s'est lancé dans les grands gagnants
comparer ce que comparables elle n'a pas
d'alliés et l'a 89 députés vous en avez
yves thréard hier hier soir hier soir
jusqu'avant les résultats convenez avec
moi qu'elle n'était en toute hypothèse
pas en situation de gouverner le pays
vous êtes d'accord avec ça non mais
c'est important vous devrez ce que hier
soir avant le résultat si nous étions
qualifiés dans m bien clair ces
résultats non mais bien sûr mais je veux
dire le résultat mais c'est aussi la
manière dont on se donne le moyen de
faire madame le pen depuis le début à
aucun moment ne s'est donné les moyens
d'être en situation elle de gouverner le
pays puisque de toute façon elle a dit
on ne peut rien faire monsieur macron à
sa majorité et elle a appelé ses
électeurs à voter pour quoi pour avoir
un groupe à l'assemblée ce que je veux
dire c'est que dimanche dernier dès lors
que nous étions qualifiés dans 4 106
circonscriptions
l'idée selon laquelle mélenchon premier
ministre n'était qu'un slogan un
mensonge a été écrasé par les faits il
faut 2 189 députés pour faire une
majorité nous étions qualifiés dans 4
106 circonscriptions
madame le pen elle était qualifiée dans
moins de 289 5 est la plus de députés
que vous non pardon 150 c + 90 à ce que
vous faites la coalition alors ça grands
noms prenons maintenant des noms yves
thréard quand vous analysez monsieur
emmanuel macron et ses petits copains
avaient séparé il vous prenait tout ça
dans l'ensemble alors que cette
récompense et qui compris dans ce cadre
là il ya beaucoup de désaccords je lui
avais vous avez mille fois raison
prenons de la hauteur et regardons un
peu les chiffres on s'aperçoit
finalement que ce qu'on dit depuis
quelques temps dans ce pays ce pays
penche vraiment à droite parce que
effectivement hier c'est le
rassemblement national qui tire bien son
épingle du jeu dans les reports de bois
on regarde un peu ce qui se passe et on
voit que c'est le rassemblement national
qui à chaque fois et bien
gagne quand même des voix
il ya les républicains qui tiennent
encore à peu près la route même si
perdre la moitié de leurs députés pas
loin et vous avez la majorité
présidentielle qui est certes composite
mais qui penche aussi pas maladroite
avec entre monsieur bayrou et monsieur
philippe donc en fait c'est tout à fait
factice
sais pas si mauvais temps opportun mais
c'est un peu factice le retour de la
gauche telle qu'elle était conçue par
monsieur mélenchon non pardon
64 parlementaires en 2010 7 x je sais
pas combien pour atterrir au résultat
d'aujourd'hui pouvaient dire que c'est à
dire que c'est factice par contre sur le
diagnostic moi je vais me mettais en
allant voir je vais mettre un peu plus
loin vous auriez carrément pu dire que
le pays penchait vers l'extrême droite
ça veut pas dire qu'il est aux mains de
l'extrême droite mais qu
incontestablement l'extrême droite
progresse dans notre pays et que c'est
un problème est que monsieur macron n'y
fait rien et que pire a même contribué à
la faire monter et ça c'est important et
donc comment on mène le combat contre le
rassemblement national certainement pas
en prenant simplement des positions de
principe de tribunaux soir de second
tour pour dire je ne sais pas quoi
exactement non c'est véritablement en
allant convaincre les gens moi je ne
connais pas
c'est à dire que c'est à dire que je ne
suis pas certain que simplement voilà
avoir une opposition de principe dire ce
sont d'affreux fasciste surtout pas que
cela soit su ça c'est triste vocabulaire
mais n'ont écouté ce qu'il y avait des
fachos fait
si bien sûr ce que nous disaient par là
c'est qu'en fait il y a des gens qui
votent rassemblement national qui ne
partagent pas la vision de fracturation
le côté identitaire voire la vision
ethniciste de l'extrême droite qui
exprime une colère mais ce que nous
avons à dire nous est ce que nous devons
porter clairement est un travail de
fourmi que de le faire et nous ne sommes
pas très aidée pour le faire j'en
conviens mais moi j'observe du compris
jusque dans ma circonscription par
exemple des endroits où le rassemblent
nationale était fort et où notre action
le fait reculer parce qu'il s'agit
d'aller convaincre parfois portes après
porte des gens qui se disent je suis en
colère parce qu'ils ont des raisons de
l'être sur la situation sociale sur leur
pouvoir d'achat et qui pensent pour une
manière qui nous échappe que madame le
pen et répond alors que concrètement
quand vous regardez les programmes le
programme de madame le pen ne
représentera pas un mieux pour toutes
ces personnes et donc il faut aller
expliqué que le problème c'est par
exemple la finance et des hyper profite
davantage que l'immigré où le voisin cas
pas la bonne couleur de peau la bonne
religion et sa remarqué que plus
personne
ne fait pas non plus logique
pardon madame martichoux mais quand on
met qu'un stress quand dans l'express
vous aviez un emmanuel macron qui
entre deux lignes vous réhabiliter de
quelques mots pétain ou maurras quand
vous avez un ministre de l'intérieur à
valeurs actuelles quand vous êtes quand
vous avez un ministre c'est pire quand
vous avez un ministre de l'intérieur sur
le plateau du service public qui vient
dire à madame le pen qu'elle est trop
molle pardon vous dire que si je veux
dire emmanuel macron est assez tacticien
alors pour avoir organisé les conditions
cette montée parce qu'il a toujours
considéré à raison d'ailleurs ça s'est
vérifié à deux reprises que face à
madame le pen il serait réélu quoi qu'il
arrive il a joué avec le feu pendant ce
quinquennat on a vu quelque chose qui
s'appelle et gilet jaune dont on n'a
certainement pas tiré toutes les
conclusions et qu'on n'a pas su avec les
analyser c'est clair j'ai regardé moi un
peu le vote là derrière ou est ce que le
front national le rassemblement national
pendant progresse dans cette france
suburbaines qui est à 100 km ou 200
kilomètres des grandes métropoles
l'heure le loiret l'aube la marne la
haute-marne est ce que justement madame
le pen n'a pas tiré peut-être davantage
que vous et elle a aussi été devant vous
à l'élection présidentielle eh bien les
enseignements de cet épisode que
personne n'avait vu venir s'ils ont ceci
fut du point de vue des revendications
du mouvement des gilets jaunes telles qu
elles sont apparues je ne le crois pas
je crois clairement que dans les
revendications qui était celle de ce
mouvement encore une fois si on n'est
pas juste sur instinctivement ce qu'on
pense mais qu'on regarde les
propositions sur la question fiscale par
exemple je crois clairement que le
programme de la nouvelle union populaire
et ô combien plus en réponse à ces
revendications que celui du
rassemblement national pour le reste est
ce que vous évoquez sur presque la
situation géographique en fait de
répartition l'électorat j'entends ma
cette petite musique sur le thème c'est
vrai c'est parfois ce qui se passe en
gironde aussi vous avez vu la jirs oui
mais c'est vrai que nous avons un
électorat plutôt urbain c'est vrai mais
on peut pas généraliser pardon mais j'ai
noté un les cartons que nous faisons des
départements dont vous ne pouvez pas
dire qu'ils ne sont pas ruraux en
haute-vienne en dordogne dans le tarn
c'est pas c'est pas la ville tout ça le
gard les hautes pyrénées ils sont
traditionnellement de gauche c'est donc
ce n'est pas une question de géographie
d'accord c'est à dire que l'on retrouve
aussi parfois peu ou prou assez de
manière assez claire la lancer une carte
de répartition gauche droite dans le
pays donc tout ça n'est pas complètement
mort et on peut pas le simplifier à mon
avis comme ça vient d'être fait est ce
que vous avez à dire question réparé
bref dernière question l'organe est à la
cuisine je fais la cuisine et je reviens
alors dans l'assemblée est-ce que
vous pourriez imaginer faire une
présidence tournante de la commission
des finances si vous la demande et en
qualité du ps mais une président surnom
d' ancrage au sein la nouvelle union
populaire oui je pense que ça on peut
l'envisager
par contre tournée avec les républicains
d'un nom ça on peut on peut l'envisager
sans doute moi je suis pour qu'on trouve
les solutions pour essayer de d'affichés
et de donner à voir la puissance que
représentait l'espoir qu'a suscitée la
constitution de cette nouvelle union
populaire voyez j'ai été surpris de voir
à quel point en quatre cinq semaines de
campagne le terme de nuque et le v de la
victoire par exemple s'est très
fortement ancrée je pense à la jeunesse
pour celle qui s'est mobilisée parce que
beaucoup manquer à l'appel donc voilà
nous avons soulevé un espoir crée même
une culture commune et je crois que ça
n'est que le début de l'aventuré pour
cette nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale qui tôt ou tard je
vous le dis le plus tôt sera le mieux
viendra aux affaires dans ce pays ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'une nouvelle page
s'ouvre à l'assemblée nationale avec
votre groupe et avec les autres
effectivement qui composent une
physionomie de l'hémicycle 2 à fait
différent et dont on sait pas très bien
comment elle va fonctionner mais on va
suivre ça de très près sur lcp dans un
discours public merci beaucoup merci
d'être venus ce soir dans l'émission
merci s'il trouve évidemment la semaine
prochaine il va se passer beaucoup
beaucoup de choses à vue toutes les
oreilles à des événements politiques
conséquemment enfin consécutivement
évidemment à l'élection législative
bonne semaine à tous à lundi prochain
19h30
[Musique]